Hace días que se espera la noticia el
primero en confirmar el inicio de la
contraofensiva ucraniana fue el
presidente ruso primero que todo
definitivamente podemos afirmar que esta
ofensiva ucraniana comenzó
a dar por iniciado el contraataque pero
zelansky decidió responder chicos
es interesante lo que Putin dijo a
propósito de nuestra contraofensiva es
importante que Rusia siempre sienta que
no le queda mucho tiempo en mi opinión
se están llevando a cabo acciones
defensivas y contraofensivas en Ucrania
etapa en la que no hablar en detalle
en este sentido las versiones en el
terreno son contradictorias ucraneas
atribuyó un importante Avance en la
línea del frente cercano de la ciudad de
bagwood capturada por las fuerzas
invasoras más de un kilómetro según
autoridades militares pero este no es el
único foco bélico activo según el
Ministerio de defensa ruso sus fuerzas
repelieron varios ataques ucranianos en
la dirección de saporilla a las
operaciones activas de las unidades de
las tropas orientales los ataques de la
Aviación y la artillería del ejército
repelieron dos ataques del enemigo con
fuerzas de hasta un Batallón
Moscú publicó un video de su ataque
contra los tanques enemigos en esa zona
el objetivo de las fuerzas ucranianas en
saponilla supondría cortar la conexión
entre las zonas del donbas y crimea
ocupadas por Rusia